[Música]
Shakira y bizarrap pueden llorar Sí pero
de alegría por todo lo que van a poder
facturar los números son impactantes en
24 horas cerca de 64 millones de
personas vieron en YouTube el vídeo y la
canción es la más escuchada de la
historia en 24 horas en español también
en Spotify donde en 24 horas 14,4
millones de personas la escucharon
récords que llegaron hasta Twitter donde
la colombiana se convirtió en la persona
más mencionada del mundo por qué fue tan
exitoso porque se llegó a jugar con las
audiencias de los tres que son
audiencias que usualmente no interactúan
No es igual la persona que siga Piqué
que la que sigue a bizarrap que la que
sigue a girar Estos tipos de
personalidades generan pasiones muy
intensas en sus audiencias lo que llevó
a que hubiera muchos memes polémica
comentarios muy intensos y que la gente
quisiera tomar partido de esta situación
el país de Guardian y cómo no nuestra en
inglés redes sociales medios de
comunicación e incluso en conversaciones
de bar todo el mundo habla de la canción
del momento y fue tal su éxito que
marcas que no tienen nada que ver están
tratando de montarse en esta situación
porque ya no es algo que beneficie
únicamente a Shakira sino un fenómeno
cultural la canción pasó de ser un
sencillo a volverse un fenómeno digital
en el que quieren estar implicados
muchos más de los netamente presentes
Más allá del fenómeno digital y de
marketing expertos de todas las
disciplinas han hecho sus propios
análisis con debates sesudos de
feminismo capitalismo y hasta la
reivindicación del orgullo
latinoamericano